[Musique]
cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois nous vous proposons de
venir voir ou revoir le neuvième épisode
star wars
l'ascension de skywalker en version
numérique française 2d ou 3d
l'occasion également pour vous de
découvrir ou redécouvrir l'exposition
dédiée à la guerre des étoiles dans nos
locaux faites vite car elle se termine
ce dimanche 12 janvier une semaine
variés dans notre programmation puisque
nous proposons des films d'animation
pour petits et grands avec vicky le
viking à partir de 3 ans les incognitos
ce à partir de 6 ans ou encore sous
avertissement le fantastique film de
jérémy clapin j'ai perdu mon corps ayant
reçu cinq prix et six nominations en
2019 un hommage aux membres fantômes aux
disparus sans doute l'un des meilleurs
films d'animation français des années
2010 en sortie nationale nous avons
également le fabuleux film d'animation
l'extraordinaire voyage de marc ona deux
ans qu'à damian qui a été nommé trois
fois au festival du film d'animation
d'annecy en 2019 enfin nous terminerons
par les deux drames la vérité qui met en
scène les retrouvailles d'une mère
actrice jouée par catherine deneuve et
de sa fille est le dernier de terrence
malick très primé traîneau mais intitulé
une vie cachée fiction inspirée de faits
réels nous exposant la résistance nazi
du temps de la seconde guerre mondiale
nous vous invitons donc à venir voir la
variété à l'espace philippe noiret et
nous en profitons pour vous souhaiter
une excellente année 2020 et tous nos
voeux de bonheur
[Musique]